dan the man what is up my man how we
doing a couple days ago
i got a call from my co-worship leader
and she said that she was stepping down
immediately due to some uh inappropriate
text
that her and my pastor have been having
in this last week
and so are you on staff at this church
yes i am yes me and her are
co-worship leaders and we have a band
about
uh eight people and me and her just
leave together
um i joined this church about a year ago
and i this pastor is one of my dearest
friends
and uh so just to dive into that phone
call a little bit
at the very first of the phone call she
wouldn't give me any details she just
said that she was stepping down
because of some circumstances that had
happened and she would not
tell me what was going on she just kept
saying that this would put me in a
corner if i knew
but then she'd kind of give me some
hints along the way
and i honestly i'll be honest i did pry
quite a bit
and um and then i asked her if i swore
to secrecy
if she would tell me oh no dan
yeah yeah so you sort of secrecy and
then she threw a grenade at you huh
well and she said she wouldn't tell me
and i and and then i
uh all she would tell me is she said
this had nothing to do with with the
band and nothing to do with the sound
people nothing to do with the church
board
and she said that's all she would tell
me as far as leadership would go
and she just gave me these hints and
then i finally guessed it and then she
told me
and um and this this pastor is actually
one of my dearest friends he's a mentor
to me he's given me marital advice
before
and she just she just kept telling me
that she felt like she had to fall on
the sword for this one and that she was
only 25
to blame but she she said she had kind
of toyed around a little bit to see
if he was serious and test the waters
and she said that she wasn't proud of it
but this wasn't her first rodeo
with doing this before sure and
um so let's hold on so i want to stop
with her
let's just put her she's made this phone
call now i want to talk about you
okay so for people who are not in the
church world
and people who are not on staff at a
church
here's what i'm hearing really quick is
the complexity here
you have a co-worker who swore you to
secrecy
but she really wanted you to pry and
find out
which you pride and you found out that
she
was being inappropriate with your boss
who happens to be the senior pastor and
your good friend
and a spiritual advisor to you and
a marriage advisor to you and she chose
to step down
and the one side of the story you have
here is that it was mostly him but
i went fishing and i've done this before
and
i know how to do this but it was mostly
him and so
you are in eight different rocks in a
hard place it feels like you're not but
it feels like it
yes and rock number one is i swear i
wouldn't tell rock number two is i have
a friend
who by any stretch of the imagination
friendship is about
vulnerability and friendship is about
openness and friendship's about
accountability
and then number three how are you going
to worship at a church where the boss is
doing that
right no yes i'm sorry this is heavy but
yes
no it i mean it it's very heavy and i
don't want to make light of it but your
path forward is relatively simple
okay so you'll hear me say this a lot on
this show
because it's our life
and it is not by your hand but in your
lap
okay so somebody just dropped something
in your lap and now you got to deal with
it did you cause it
no is it your fault no
but you do have a responsibility to deal
with that and that can be trashing
that's blowing down your street that can
be a um
neighbor who you've got to go knock on
the door and have a hard conversation
with it could be a teacher that treats
your kid wrong whatever the thing is
it's not
you didn't cause it but now you got to
deal with it right that's life
how old are you man i am 27.
all right so if you haven't experienced
this before this will be a hardest thing
you've ever walked through
and it will be a cornerstone of who you
become
the minister you become the pastor you
become and if you choose to quit all
this and get out and go sell insurance
it's gonna be a cornerstone of the
person you become because you're gonna
have to do something hard
okay yeah um and for everybody out there
never ever ever say the words
i promise i won't tell you
i promise i won't tell because you never
know what someone's gonna put
on you you never know what someone's
gonna put on you
and you learn this the hard way dan
but i am not in the business if somebody
doesn't want to tell me i'm going to
move on with my life
yeah you know what i mean that is their
secret their burden their whatever to
carry
but the next time you'll know that if
someone calls and says hey i have to
emergency step down um there's some
things that happen behind closed doors
and i got to go
then you will say oh my gosh i'll be
thinking about you
we'll be praying for you i wish you the
best of luck and if i could ever be of
service you know or
how to get a hold of me and then you
hang up and let him go and then your
next call is to the boss
right not to pry from that person and
you let the boss know that somebody said
something like
uncouth is going on but anyway that's
where we're at right now right so
your path forward and again i feel like
i'm doing this in the second call in a
row here
to being pretty prescriptive but you got
to let her know
that you shouldn't have pride
you did and you can't keep that that
confidential period
and the next thing you have to do is go
directly to your friend
in person and say here's what's in my
lap
yep and you gotta do that i agree
and that's that's honestly i just needed
the permission to do that because
i know that you know scripture says in
matthew to confront your neighbor
if if they are sinning and if this is
true and
and so i i feel like i i owe him the
respect
and to do this and just to to let you
know also and i feel like this is
important to share but
what's even more crazy is that my pastor
and his wife
in two different situations about a
month ago
privately with me let me know
and and they let me know to be aware
of this other worship leader and that
she's not happy in her marriage and that
to not be alone in situations with her
because
she uh prized for attention in it and
i'm
a kind of guy that just loves to love
people
and they said that you know it can be
taken as flirtatious if someone wants
attention
and uh what's crazy is my pastor even
said i just want you to be aware and i
don't want you to ever be alone in
situations with her
just to protect your marriage because it
could always be a he shed she said thing
and i don't ever want to put you in that
predicament
so that's why i'm so confused well and
here's
where this is this is really important
this is why you
with no fanfare no drama no
calling in the calvary this is why you
as a grown man
go sit down one on one with your other
grown man friend
okay and you say here's what i was told
i have a feeling that he may pull his
phone out and say
i'll show you what happened and your
eyes will bug out of your head once you
get the other side of the story
okay and reserve your judgments
reserve your grenades for him reserve
your
disdain for him and the role of the
church and partridge in a pear tree
here's the thing he may be a scumbag
he may have had one one
singular lap lapse in judgment one
yep and he may have received a bunch of
crazy text messages from somebody
immediately showed his wife immediately
gone to his
his bosses right the eldership or
whatever leaders are at your particular
denomination
and said whoa and to which
somebody stepped in and said you need to
resign right away to this other worship
leader
she did and now she's spinning story you
know all that to say is you don't know
yeah and so your job is to go sit down
and say
here's what was told to me and
it's my job as your friend who loves you
and um who has invested in you and
you've invested in me
to put this out there and know that this
is being said about you
and this is out there and then let him
speak
and here's the thing dan you may not get
resolution on this
that's what i'm worried about right
sometimes your resolution is gonna be
i did the right thing and then the truth
will find its way out
sometimes the resolution on something is
finding another side of a story
right um if you're great friends with
him and he denies the whole thing you
may say dude show me your text right now
and he may pull your phone out right
away right
or you may be able to say dude can you
can you show me and i've got friends in
my life who would do that to me
by the way yeah right and is your heart
going to be beating fast yes
is this going to be awkward yes is this
going to be uncomfortable yes
but is this what you have to do yeah it
is
it is if you get a sense that he's
lying and shady and like skeptical and
weird
then it's fair to put him on notice that
i'm gonna give this seven days and then
i'm gonna go talk to
to my bosses there at the church if i
think you're not being honest with me
then
i've got a responsibility to this this
entire group of people who attend this
church
who work at this place um that they
know what was dropped in my lap
but i think the right thing to do is to
go to him directly first
right now quick aside and dan i'm just
i'm not speaking to you i'm speaking
anybody else listening to this
if this is a kid in the youth group
whole different conversation
this is a kid in the youth group if this
is a
kid in like uh sunday school
then we're calling in the calvary we're
turning all the lights on in the
building and we'll figure stuff out
later
but that's when i'm gonna have a much
louder conversation
than a personal hey someone just quit
and they said it was because you were
making them feel uncomfortable they said
it was because you
were hitting on them and you're married
they're married something feels oogy
about this and they said they had to
quit
dude what in the world this doesn't
sound like you this isn't the guy i know
this isn't the
pastor that i know but i have to sit
down and look your eye and say i'm not
cool with this what's going on
so that's my thoughts dan i appreciate
the call and again
that's a lot of responsibility for a 27
year old um
and that's what you signed up for you're
in this role for a reason
i do want you to do this i want you to
have this hard conversation and please
email me back
please call me back i'd love to have you
back on the show and let everybody know
how that conversation went
um one of the things that we don't do
well as a culture as a society is have
hard conversations and so
i want to hear how it went and it may
help for you to write bullet points down
right it may be helpful for you to
practice this conversation
with your wife or in the mirror or
whatever that may be but
make sure you are clear-headed and
clear-mind-minded and
go talk to your friend he deserves that
you deserve that and
the people in that church deserve that